you're a very nice guy you're just
conservative that's the dirty little
secret though talk about that but this
is one of the things that bothers me so
much about you being so misrepresented
when I read things about you there was a
the article that we were just talking
about the alt-right sage without the
rage they called you and your moat Lee
all right in fact you were the leading
target of anti-semitic abuse for all of
2016 weren't you I'm going to the
anti-defamation league which is no la
mine so yeah I mean I'm not only am I
not all right I've spent the last four
years like legitimately battling the
alt-right talking about how evil I think
their ideology is how evil I think white
supremacy is I mean first of all like
people with the Amika is typically not
the favorites of the alright and then
beyond that I mean I think their
ideology is legitimately a devastatingly
awful twist on what Western civilization
is supposed to be was amazing as a
review of my new book and my new book
has several sections and they're
dedicated to how terrible the alt-right
is and then the interview they did with
me doesn't talk about alright stuff at
all but they just assume I'm on the
conservative right that must mean that I
am alright it's like no you stupid
labels they're disingenuous people are
labeling people in a very simple manner
to try to categorize them as the enemy
and instead of just addressing these
points like I love watching your debates
where you do Q&A s with college students
and with people in the audience because
you can see you agree with you or
disagree with you you have well
formulated ideas this isn't just some
bullshit that you're spouting out you've
thought these things through I've been
doing this for legitimately more than
half my life I'm 35 and I started when I
was 17 and I started writing a
syndicated column at that point and when
you're 17 you think a lot of dumb stuff
and then you get older and you educate
yourself and you spend a lot at a time
reading and a lot of time studying
hopefully you have some cogent arguments
after 20 years of doing anything I mean
but it's the the demonization is pretty
astonishing me we had an on Andrew yang
he's the only Democratic candidate who
has agreed to go on the Sunday special
that I do we did a full hour on ubi it
was perfectly nice it was perfectly
coherent and and and conciliatory and
yet people will suggest that everything
I do is about destroying people on the
other side because of all the Ben
Shapiro destroys videos and all that
there's there are certain groups of
people where that's their stick they're
like they're goons right they just go
after people online for attention yes
this is a stick this is not you and this
is what bothers me so much and I know
that you've said some things in the past
like particularly about Arabs and like
when you were a younger man you said I
should have said that yeah that's
exactly right
some of those things were taken out of
context like that one particular tweet
which is a bad tweet was a tweet that
was part of a tweet threat in which I
was specifically contrasting Israel and
the Hamas leadership and saying that the
Israeli government likes to build and
the Hamas leadership would prefer that
their citizens live in sewage and bomb
things but that was a bad tweet
obviously my entire history on on Muslim
relations is one like I supported the
ability of Ilhan Omar to wear a hijab on
the on the floor I opposed president
Trump's originally proposed Muslim ban
in the last three weeks I've had on
machine awaaz I've had on contact med I
had on yesterday a reformed Muslim like
these are conversations that have to be
had but to take this is one of things
that bugs me so much I've tweeted I
think a hundred and forty thousand times
I've written millions of words I'm sure
you can find something I don't even
remember having written it is bad I have
a running list by the way I try to be
honest about this I'm one of the only
people I know who has I have a running
list it's called so here is a giant list
of all the dumb stuff I've ever done
right and I actually go through all the
see like you can look it up this is not
me saying this now I mean you can go and
look up all the things that I think I've
done wrong and I'll apologize for some
and I'll say somewhere dumb and I'll say
some I'm fine with and you're just
taking out of context but I mean that I
hope that's what honest people try to do
but this is the problem you're not
dealing with honest people when people
try to categorize you is all right or
they're trying to put you into this
category of Internet goon they're they
and they quote tweet there's taking some
little tiny phrase that you said seven
years ago and trying to say this is you
this is you now it's so that's such a
disingenuous thing to do I hate it and i
hate it across the aisle by the way i
was a defender of james gunn I thought
James Gunn should have been fired from
guardians of the galaxy jokes and even
if somebody tweeted something bad like
10 years ago bringing it up now is not
an attempt
actually make the public space better
and you're not actually offended by that
thing the person tweeted ten years ago
that you didn't notice what it is that
you want to get rid of this person or
hurt this person so you're gonna bring
up something from ten years ago and then
you're gonna try and Club them into
submission with it because if you
actually ask them their opinion about it
they might have a more nuanced view on
what they said maybe they apologized
maybe they think I don't even remember
saying that right I mean I felt the same
way by the way I try to be consistent I
really do about about this stuff I said
the same thing about for example Ralph
Northam the the governor of Virginia who
is excoriated for having this terrible
racist photo on his yearbook page back
in medical school in 1987 and people are
saying well this is evidence he's racist
now I was like well no that's evidence
that he was doing a racist thing then
that's not evidence that he's racist now
you sort of have to look over the broad
course of his career and he ended up
doing what everyone now does which is
you just don't apologize for anything
you just try to pass it off as in
nothing the public space is actually
getting worse because let's say that you
did something bad in the past there are
a few human responses to I did something
I don't like him past human response
number one is you know what I apologize
that was wrong these days that gets your
face stuff done right you say I
apologize I was wrong it means well why
did you do it in the first place because
you're a bad person
apologies are not accepted and then
number two is you brazen it out you do
the Trump you know what I never did
anything wrong ever
I've never perfect right and that and
then you get your defenders to come and
surround you and then nothing ever gets
cleansed or opportunity number three is
you do what Barack Obama did which is
you come out preemptively and you try to
remember all the bad stuff you do and
then you confess it in public so in
dreams for my father he says right well
you know when I was back in high school
did a little blow and everything go okay
so he did cocaine when he was in high
school that's that's cool whereas if it
comes out during the campaign right Stan
he's boned right then he's got he's got
a real problem the problem is that right
now even if you preemptively come out
and say I did something wrong like for
example Liam Neeson talking about years
ago when he had a racist thought that he
didn't act on when he had a racist
thought this is now we're gonna try and
ruin your career for something that you
admit was bad that you did 30 years ago
we're gonna try and run you over that if
you apologize for something that you did
30 years ago which she would have
preferred just got forgotten because it
was embarrassing and stupid then we say
you're bad and so all you're left with
is like the most shameless people in
world who are in the public space right
the incentive structure is to be deeply
shameless to just say yeah man I own
that and it was great when I said it or
I didn't say it at all
and you're just full of it I never said
that stuff who you gonna believe your
eyes or me and it makes it makes for a
really bad politics well it's just this
the culture of going after people for
things and and finding anything to
categorize them as someone who's a
viable target and this is what I've seen
thrust your way it's like there's
nothing wrong with being conservative
there's something wrong with wanting
everyone to think the way you think
though this is the difference like you
what I like that you do is you debate
your points you state your positions you
have a philosophy and what I don't like
is when people try to pretend that that
philosophy is some somewhat somehow
hateful or somehow regressive or
something like your that you condemn
people for their thoughts you you just
you don't this is what not what I see
with you I appreciate it and I
appreciate the accuracy exciting that's
true I mean I've come out against
virtually every Twitter ban including
people who have personally targeted me
I've come out against that I've come out
against virtually every what you know
let's talk about that because what do
you what are your thoughts about this
idea of the platforming and you know
this is something that we were just
discussing before the podcast where the
CEO of YouTube and Kara Swisher
yeah from Rico I think Kara Swisher they
were talking about removing you from
YouTube and I thought it was the CEO of
YouTube it was actually Carol who said I
would if I could
yeah she's pissed because her son
apparently listens to that's kind of
funny
she's being funny saying I could but it
was I thought it was the CEO of YouTube
mister she was trying to do the same
thing that they do with you or with Dave
Rubin or Jordan Peterson which is that
anybody who is sort of heterodox because
in that group I think I'm the only
registered Republican ever anybody who's
heterodox is now being explored really
dogs meaning just thinks differently
from kind of the down the line
democratic party platform you're not
like down the line with Hillary yeah
like Sam Harris is a Democrat Sam Harris
is heterodox because he disagrees that
Islam is by necessity a religion of
peace for example right or he thinks
that we have to look at actual
statistics in order to make
evidentiary base points about
discrimination and disparity mm-hm and
this makes him an enemy of people like
Ezra Klein at voxcom right this sort of
stuff
they then say that you are a feeder for
white supremacy right they they can't
actually get you on what you say yeah so
it turns into well you know some members
of your audience do things that that are
really bad there's like well dude I have
like millions of people who are members
of my audience have five million
Facebook followers I have two million on
Twitter and you're way bigger than I am
I assume that some of those people are
gonna be crazy yeah I would assume yeah
the idea that your response what YouTube
tried to do you know about the comment
thing where the YouTube was gonna try to
make people responsible for the comments
in their videos which what is a normal
Jamie like a normal video that we get
how many comments is a good fuck am I
supposed to have some dude with this
itchy trigger fingers standing by in
front of a keyboard just waiting for
something offensive to pop up and this
was in response to something that
happened with them where there was
pedophiles who were watching videos of
children doing things and they were
commenting stuff in the you know like
the children's gymnastics and stuff like
that they're commenting and like
communicating with each other through
the comments and it was sort of
discovered that there was this
connection that they were doing this in
many many videos and YouTube rightly
panicked and like holy shit we have to
stop this so the response I guess was we
just have to make people responsible for
their comments someone said oh yeah good
idea
you didn't think through it at all right
you know certain people that can't do
that it's totally insane and it's insane
and in virtually every respect and it's
it's funny how it's only applied kind of
by the media on one side of the aisle so
to take an example the Congressional
baseball shooting happens a couple of
years ago guy happens to be a Bernie fan
is that Bernie Sanders is fault right no
that is not Bernie Sanders is that went
away right literally people stopped
talking about it and that was shooting
of legislators like elected people one
nearly died and that kind of went away
we don't talk about you know Bernie's
responsibility but there's a shooting in
Christchurch and it's Jordan Peterson
small and John Peterson has no
relationship with the shooter whatsoever
it's my fault I have no relationship
with the shooter and did announce
everything that that piece of crap
stands for